hello my name is marlene english and i'm
from the netherlands and i'm the right
digidesign actors heart is too cloudy
urine we ran another year in the
northern part of the netherlands to
islam and we make depa stories Depa
streets or felt but the story behind
every story about how we do it is very
special and I showed it in the lecture I
gave so many as ago here we see cloudy
looks of the artist in the United
Nations and with the Texas behind her
and we've discarded the background I can
show what we try to achieve with our we
have our own Trent Yves sheep because we
want to preserve this dismal specialist
and never own botanical garden with
dying plants and we have started also
our own fields with diamonds we try to
preserve the natural heritage those are
the culture heritage reason why I'm in
Davao plow and uniqueness that we want
to inspire a political and business
manager take care on the preservation of
natural heritage but also the cultural
heritage there are so many beautiful
flowers plants leaves she and there may
be not working in an economical way but
if we lose these species there will be
something gone forever it's the same for
all skills like weaving nothing and we
try to interfere this into our services
and that's why we will make the stances
of every buildings so my lecture was of
course about making these territories
and equals production chain but at the
same time we had a discussion about the
necessity with we think for everybody to
do yeah oh joy the inspiration of nature
and the joy and pleasure of having your
own skills and making things on culture
is made from nature so I've been to the
lecture of come on strong this morning
and she talks about
everybody has been the world has painted
it's something clouded me feel also
ourselves we are really dedicated to
bring some joy to make some happiness
and to being a beautiful are you into
public buildings because empower people
to enlighten salute to show this and I
think in the lecture if I see all the
questions that have been asked during
after I gave my presentation the women
and the men were asking so many things
hours do you work with her people have
you been making tapestries in hospitals
and I noticed all right I touched we
touched something in their heart and in
their spirits and that's really what you
want to do these natural resources these
colors from nature are so dead tired so
lively and so beautiful and you should
you should touch them you should smell
them and you have your own sentence to
do much to be aware of the power of the
necessary well I think I've seen you
save you can most important things of
course I hate there were some directions
forum for people in the public and and
that they spread it was constantly
taking care thank you